[Music]
weston's with us in nashville hey weston
welcome to the ramsay show
howdy sir thank you for taking my call
sure what's up
hey so i am also a nurse i'm on baby
step four and what my question is is
should i i have money set aside to go to
seminary right now because i'm wanting
to change careers but should i use that
money to to go to seminary or should i
use that money to uh make a down payment
on a home wow
from nursing to seminary
yes sir that's a pretty that's an
interesting call i like it yes sir uh
how old are you
26 years old sir okay when will you
enter seminary if you don't buy a house
and have the money
if i don't buy a house then i i could do
it um january and you would take you how
long
to complete seminary
three years i would get my masters in
divinity sir okay all right what's the
goal what's the end
the end result
the end goal is i would love to be a
pastor and that's why like i've read
your book proximity principle what i
want to do is i want to faithfully serve
um
serve the people of
serve god's people
and what i've been doing is obviously
reading my bible reading reading the the
books and and serving as best as i can
what i'm concerned about is that i won't
be fully educated to serve as best as i
can not really i'm not chasing a degree
i'm not chasing a piece of paper i'm
just chasing the maximum amount of
education yes sir yes sir
well you're aware there's a lot of
highly effective pastors that do not
have an md yeah
yes sir okay my dad pastored started two
churches pastored for 47 years and did
not get his mdf now he did go to bible
college and he did a lot of studying and
the guy read commentaries still reads
commentaries um so i think that what
you've got to understand is there is
opportunity for you to get more biblical
knowledge
to learn and continue to learn whether
you have an mdiv or not now i'm not
trying to talk you out of doing an mdiv
but i do think you've got to understand
that there are multiple pathways
um
and different levels of education none
of which it's not table stakes in that
yeah that's right
i mean the knowledge that you get from
mdf there's not table stakes
to be a pastor
uh uh and so i want you to understand
that and so then that makes me back up
and say i i want you to go i'm more
worried about seminary and more worried
about you going into the ministry than i
am you buying a house so let's just put
take the house off the table and let's
move towards uh move towards your new
career as fast as we can
and um but i
i
might add some steps to your career
transition to see if you really
want to spend the money and the time on
an mdiv you don't have to spend three
years to get an mdf to be qualified so
let's let's play this out are you
wanting to be a senior pastor as it
stands today at 26.
is that the goal
eventually but i don't i don't think
right now i have the spiritual no no no
no no no no no no no and you don't and
it's okay but let's let's back this up
now if right now this can change we know
it's ministry but it could be senior
pastor maybe you find as you get into it
that you'd rather be an executive pastor
that's just as much ministry as a as a
person who's preaching on sundays i
think you've got to actually look to get
in
in a volunteer ministry position you're
a nurse right now you're in great shape
financially i want to see you try to
work towards a part-time so right now
volunteer and then try to move to a
part-time ministry position churches
need folks like you who they can't pay
full-time and but they need somebody to
step in and i would i would truly work
the proximity principle which for the
audience says in order to do what you
want to do ministry pastoral work got to
be around people that are doing it in
place where it is happening get in and
sample and taste and see
all the different types of ministry
positions at 26 you can learn a lot just
from doing that dave and then you
volunteer a little bit maybe a part-time
role and you start
at a bible college that would count
towards an mdiv yeah but don't wait to
start your ministry until you finish
them diff yeah get into and see what you
know maybe it's youth maybe it's singles
maybe it's you know pastoral care where
you spend your whole week visiting
people um counseling is a form of
ministry and then of course the senior
pastor or the executive pastor really
need to get in and see it taste it
experience a little bit of it and then
at 26 27 28 you get a better idea which
path you want to walk
and we're throwing around inside
baseball terms mdiv stands for masters
in divinity
for those of you that are wondering what
the flip we're talking about that's
right but um yeah get a master's degree
in seminary is what it amounts to and um
it certainly qualifies you to do a lot
of things in the in the church world
without a doubt the knowledge base does
not the piece of paper and he's
approaching that from the right angle
but to answer your overall question i
would put your career shift
ahead of purchasing a home right now uh
you've got plenty of time to buy a home
later
and um
[Music]
it's a weird market to buy in any way
right this second uh like there's 9 000
buyers for every house that's for sale
and that kind of stuff and so um you
know it's not a bad time to sit on the
sidelines anyway and let's just take
some steps but i might take a different
step than saying i got to go get an mdf
before i'm
qualified knowledge base wise to do
ministry not true
um not true that's not it's not an
accurate one of my dear friends when
stacey and i lived in richmond virginia
when we first got married went to a
church and the pastor there was probably
32 and was in his first senior pastor
job had worked his way into it and he
got his mdiv while being a pastor yeah
i've got i know several guys so that's
that's a very normal path as well sure
and the church will pay for it yes most
of the time it's not unusual at all i've
been in several situations where the
associate pastor was working you know
continuing i mean it's continual
personal growth in your field of
endeavor and so you've got to do
something to continue your personal
growth and
um
you know ignorance is not good in any
field
so um yeah that that's not an unusual
growth path for someone sitting in an
associate pastor role or a young adult's
pastor role or whatever to be working on
that and many times the church if it's a
church of size will pay for it